- Hi, I'm Jake Gyllenhaal.
And this is how I became Mysterio.
When they pitched Mysterio to me,
they were like, he's
gonna be the new Avenger.
He's gonna be one of the
new members of the MCU.
And they needed a specific
type of actor I think
to be able to pull that off.
And I just loved that.
I mean, I love that, you
know, they need a particular
kind of skill set to play this part.
Which was just exciting to me.
And when Jon Watts
approached me about Mysterio,
I thought, oh my god,
there's so many interesting
facets to him, and his
back story's really cool.
And I do this thing whenever I'm looking
at a character where I'm always like
if they're one way,
I'm always wondering if
there's the opposite way to play it.
Or if it's the opposite way,
I'm always looking for the other way.
I think people tend to write things
or they tend to think of things very like,
oh this person's a good person,
or this person's a bad person.
I think we're much more complex than that,
generally speaking.
And I get so bored of
villains, or bad guys,
or women in movies that are, you know,
they're mustache twirling
and they're just bad
'cause they want something.
And they just have this sort
of, they want the money,
they want the power, blah, blah, blah.
And it's become less interesting to me.
So playing that in a world where
I think his logic makes a lot of sense.
You know, he says something very clear,
regardless of the power that, you know,
should be bestowed, it
shouldn't be bestowed
on somebody who is not
mature enough to hold it.
Because he knows the power of these things
that Tony has created.
And the power of the MCU.
And he respects it.
I don't think there's a moment
where he doesn't respect it.
And I just think he needs to make sure
all this work that he's done, with Tony,
is in the right hands.
And that really is the
intention I had the entire time.
And I don't think that's a bad intention.
I think that's actually a really,
really, really good intention.
It gets bad when he feels like, in order
to get that message across,
people need to get hurt.
And that's that not very fine line,
but that is the line that separates him.
But his intention always has to be good.
And I don't ever wanna
play a character who just,
is just bad, like is just
bad purely, you know.
He always believes he's
doing the right thing.
I mean the Quentin Beck, or you know,
the number of aliases that
he goes under in the comics,
his intention always is basically envy.
It's based on jealousy.
But he uses this idea of illusion
and psychoanalysis, and all these sort of,
all this knowledge he has
to manipulate situations.
It's different because I think
his intention is actually
a better intention than
it ever is in the comics.
And I don't think my Quentin
Beck, or my Mysterio,
wants to really mess with Peter.
I feel like he has to.
And there is a distinct difference there.
Because I think if you really get into it,
a lot of times you see
characters like this
go, you know, oh, ha, ha,
ha, you shouldn't have
found yourself here Peter, you know.
Oh, like I've told you so
many times never to walk
across this bridge and now
here you are, you know.
And I was like, no, I
need to play a character
that tells him never to
walk across that bridge,
and then he does, and he proves to me
that he's not mature enough
to wield all this power,
by walking across that bridge.
And I say, man, I told you
not to walk across the bridge.
Like I told you, almost like a parent.
And now you are, and now we
have to do something about it.
And that makes it just
so much more complex
for a lesson for Peter.
Because as you grow up
the world becomes much more complicated.
And I think that's what's
so cool about this movie,
is the world becomes so much
more complicated for Peter.
- It's really nice to
have somebody to talk to
about superhero stuff, you know.
- Anytime.
The first scene I ever shot was the scene
where I enter and I
throw those green lasers
out of my hands, that you
don't want any part of this.
I just was basically put on the suit,
thrown onset, and jumped off a platform,
and I was in the MCU.
And, you know, that's overwhelming.
And it took me about two months to like
even figure out what
the heck was going on.
So, right when I finished, I felt like,
oh, I got it now, you know.
Anybody who's searching for a new idea,
who never feels like any idea's bad,
that's what it feels
like to work with Marvel.
And now they have, over these many years,
the funds to be able to
come up with any idea.
When the best idea is there.
And they take real risks.
And to me, entertainment and all that,
but really art, is all about that.
No matter what size it is,
rather it's like for pop culture,
or whether you're doing it for two people
who don't know, that's
what it's all about.
That's the fun, that's the delight.
They just, Marvel has not lost
their delight in the process.
And I think that's why so many audiences
are delighted by the movies,
and keep coming back.
You may not be ready, but
this is my responsibility.
Well I think this movie's
really about making a movie.
And I think I get to play
like director, and producer,
and writer, and actor,
all in one character.
And I get to play good actor,
I get to play bad actor.
And I don't think you ever
know where the performance is,
which is what I love about acting anyway.
There's so many actors out there
talking about the importance
of the creative process,
which I think is really important.
And I think it's actually
really beautiful.
I mean I've devoted my life to it.
But, at the same time, I
think it's totally absurd.
And I think you have to have
a sense of humor about all of it.
And what I love about Mysterio
is he's just a comment on how amazing
and how kind of ridiculous
movies and movie making is.
And what we will believe.
And why we'll believe it.
- [Interviewer] What part of the costume
made you most feel like Mysterio?
- The pink leather g-string
that Mysterio wears
really makes me feel like the character.
Ah no.
It's the woolen cape that lights up.
It's the hot battery pack on my back,
electrifying the disco ball
that is my chest plate.
When I feel that burning
warmth on my lower backside,
that's when I really
feel like the character.
- [Interviewer] Think
we'll see Mysterio again?
- Ah, I don't know if that's up to me.
I feel like that's up to Mysterio.